Tolly Burkan. Creator of the Fire Walking Movement.
Have you ever wanted to walk on fire? Perhaps you've seen it on TV.
In fact, fire walking actually precedes written history.
Hawaiian Kahuna fire walked across lava flows.
The Vikings are reported to have walked on red - hot steel chains.
Native Americans and Fijians fire walked,...
...and a number of Christian saints were said to have fire walked.
Fire walking has been a part of many diverse cultures on a number of continents.
In modern times,...
...Tolly Burkan is known as the founding father of the international fire walking movement.
Using his pioneering methods,...
...over three million people on six continents have walked on fire.
He was taught to fire walk by a friend in 1977 and the experience so transformed him,...
...that he immediately wanted to share it with the world.
He wondered why no one was teaching fire walking to the general public.
After 30 years of sharing the experience,...
...even multinational companies routinely use his fire walking techniques in seminars...
...to improve the performance of their executives.
People who have fire walked say they have received a tremendous...
...boost in self-confidence and self-esteem...
...and believe that they can achieve whatever goals they have set in business...
...and in their personal life.
They believe they have the ability to overcome insecurity...
...and to eliminate the fear that holds them back in life.
They begin to focus on goals and not on their limitations...
...and in the process gain a memory that lasts for a lifetime.